michel larive député la france est
soumise bonsoir michel larive merci
d'être avec nous sur mtv france
en quoi va consister ce texte d'état
d'urgence sanitaire exactement alors
consister à prendre des mesures
d'urgence pour faire face à cette
urgence sanitaire mais il semblerait que
le test étant passé au sénat
il passe aujourd'hui à l'assemblée il ya
quelques différences d'appréciation
entre le sénat et l'assemblée et nous
voyons nous ce qu'il se passe au delà
dans l'hémicycle nous pensions qu'avec
le discours du président de la
république y auraient dit que les choses
évolueront il y aura un avant et un
après corona nous avons peur au vu de ce
qui est proposé à l'assemblée nationale
que ça change pour le pire
alors nous sommes d'accord pour l'unité
nationale sommes tous d'accord pour
l'unité nationale à partir du moment où
cette unité nationale s'exprime dans une
continuité démocratique et il est à
minima à recherche de consensus derrière
une concertation et là j'ai bien peur
que le gouvernement aille à marche
forcée je crois que y aura une cmp qui
aura lieu demain parce que le sénat et
l'assemblée n'ont pas l'air d'accord en
ce moment précisé ce que veut dire cmp
et sur quoi exactement vous n'êtes pas
d'accord vous dit on va vers le pire
mais c'est cette addiction
non papa bon bah je dis on va vers le
pire dans le sens des salariés nous
avions proposé nous par exemple de
rétablir les saf et 3,2 milliards de
dollars
l'état dit qu'il va injecter 45
milliards d'euros par an 45 milliards
d'euros pour aider dans cette crise sur
ces 45 milliards d'euros il ya 32
milliards de reports de charges 11
milliards 5 seulement d'être direct et
en fait l'unedic et la région en
prennent à leur charge 5,5
donc l'état lui ne donne qu'un 6.5
milliards il ya notamment des choses
qu'on pourrait faire tout de suite
plutôt que de supprimer les 35 heures
c'est de cela dont je vous parle la peur
je viens de là c'est que l'on profite
effectivement de cette crise de ces
mesures
l'urgence pour mettre à bas mettre à mal
la balle et 35e ont les congés payés et
de ne pas donner de date limite à ces
mesures d'urgence
vous aviez par exemple la possibilité de
rétablir et ça c'est 3,2 milliards qui
sont trouvés tout de suite vous aviez la
possibilité d'augmenter la taxe sur les
transactions financières de 0 3 à 0 5 %
et vous trouviez là un autre milliard et
puis la véritable urgence et
organisationnel aujourd'hui et ça je
veux me faire le relais de ce cri
d'alarmé
les soignants n'ont pas le matériel
nécessaire pour se protéger eux et
protéger les patients donc les soignants
en ce moment sont dans une position très
très difficile
la voilà la véritable urgence alors
comment pallier justement à ce manque
d'anticipation un pays comme la france
effectivement un manque donc de masques
de gants comment est ce que c'est
possible
allez y avait des décisions qui avaient
été prises par les gouvernements
précédents
je crois que sous le le gouvernement de
monsieur valls on avait arrêté n'a
d'ailleurs où on n'avait pas donné
suffisamment crédits pour la recherche
sur le corps d'un virus
les gouvernements précédents on parce
qu'il ne se passait pas de choses les
inciter à pouvoir continuer le processus
de précaution ont décidé d'arrêter de
faire des stocks de masques ou d'autre
matériel de protection
et donc voilà il nous sommes dans un
système qui voit qu'ils voyaient ils
voient encore jusque jusqu'au bout de
son nez pas plus loin
et lorsque la première crise d'ampleur
arrive eh bien nous voyons la limite de
ce système et c'est bien de ce système
dont il faudrait parler
au sortir de cette crise on en parlera
évidemment ce sera l'heure du bilan est
ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
l'imposition d'un couvre feu national
bien écoutez moi j'en appelle à la
responsabilité de tous les français de
tous les français de gucht effectivement
ils restent chez eux
mais là aussi on doit avoir un seul
discours madame penco ne peut pas
disputer comme ça les gens du bâtiment
qu'ils disent
nous avons cessé notre activité pour
pouvoir protéger nous salariés
on peut pas donner des primes de 1000
euros pour inciter les gens à sortir et
leur dire de rester chez eux
il ya un moment donné une cohérence du
discours il faut avoir et donc quant à
la question du couvre-feu je ne suis pas
en responsabilité moi je préférais que
la responsabilité des françaises et des
français
faye commun ne puisse pas en arriver à
cette mesure mais s'il le faut si les
gens ne comprennent pas donc ce serait
envisageable et et kate dernière
question comment est ce que fait
l'assemblée nationale pour fonctionner
correctement et adopté juste avant tout
ses textes
alors il ya des protocoles les
protocoles de distanciation entre chaque
individu un c'est pas justement il
faudra faire attention si au terme à
distanciation sociale c'est un peu un
terme très ambigu parce que
distanciation social sachez que les gens
des sdf et d'autres connaissable déjà
tout au long de l'année
donc là c'est la distance distanciation
entre individus ont gardé me dé la
mesure de deux barrières des mesures
barrières c'est à dire que chaque groupe
à entre deux et cinq représentants qui a
la capacité de voter pour l'ensemble du
groupe politique entier et les chanceux
se débattent dans une autre dans le
cadre de toutes les protections barrière
qui ont été signifiées par le
gouvernement merci vous pouvez celle là
aujourd'hui il est au point mort c'est à
dire que elle et elle fonctionne à
minima plus personne à part les députés
qui sont requis leur entrée dans
l'assemblée ce que je veux dire aussi la
une polémique par là haut au télétravail
le télétravail je suis président de
l'association des dépôts est employeur
le télétravail doit s'exercer d'exercer
à partir du lieu de résidence pas à
partir du lieu qu aurait choisi
l'employeur on te voilà ce que je veux
dire à bonne entendeur salut merci merci
beaucoup michel larive pour ces
précisions